may 31st marks 100 years
since the 1921 tulsa race massacre one
of the most devastating attacks against
the black community
and really in american history after
world war one
tulsa oklahoma's greenwood district also
known as black wall street
was nationally recognized as a thriving
business district and really
a haven before it was destroyed so now
we are remembering that moment
and rising through music picture this
greenwood ave red men's land shiva
[Music]
allow me to introduce you to fire in
little africa
a multimedia hip-hop project remembering
the 1921
massacre of tulsa's greenwood
neighborhood which was described by dr
view the executive producer of the
project as a real-life wakanda
the album was created with a simple
mission
to educate which is a compilation
hip-hop album commemoration
of greenwood just to tell the true story
the localized stories
of our ancestors and to really
commemorate 100 years later what was
lost
inspired by rapper j cole and dr view's
very own dissertation
which was done in the form of a hip-hop
album he made his vision
come to life we got 60 artists from
primarily the major cities tulsa
oklahoma city and lawton
this was an oklahoma project recorded
143 songs in those five days
the fire in little africa album was born
in the heart of greenwood at the
greenwood cultural center
and inside skyline mansion which was
formerly owned by one of the ringleaders
of the tulsa race massacre powerfully
representing resilience
and leading dr bu and his team to the
attention of an iconic music label
um ended up getting a meeting with
motown they said yo we want to do a deal
with you all
we want to uh distribute through black
forum
um and then not to mention we we got the
opportunity to work with beyonce's
purposes who's uh
yvette noel shore so just the national
international attention
on lulu greenwood it's just it's just
been really dope
throughout history and in the present
the black community persists
we keep fighting we keep creating
and we keep shining i always knew you
had the globe and now they see it from
the coast i'll tell them
the song itself was was was written
just to reimagine what greenwood was
like
prior to the massacre
[Music]
that you'll have a moment where you're
listening and you're like oh this sounds
really dope
but once you start to explore what the
artists are really saying it's like
oh they're really pulling back some
layers so it's we're talking about tulsa
specific
you know things history but it's really
connected to this larger discussion
around
racism gratuitous violence liberation
for black folks in america
so what does this album say to not only
the black community but
to the world i just say everything is us
because
when creatives come together
and really explore like history
and art and music and tech
and they put it all together and stir it
up
like it's it's a beautiful thing what it
looks like in a hundred years
the audacity i love that that was good
no well done
thank you you know besides jc the weight
on the shoulders of the black community
what's even more profound to me
is the joy we exude and that's what
you'll hear in this album they're even
turning it into a curriculum for schools
so that is much needed and
incredible yeah that's great great stuff
and then the album actually came out at
midnight so yeah it's available in all
streaming platforms
it is and yeah you can find more
information really cool merch like the
sweatshirt dr b was wearing
and you can even donate to their
movement at fire in littleafrica.com